welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus docker on this
episode I talk with Connor Leahy Connor
is the CEO of conjecture which is a new
organization researching scalable AI
alignment
we talk about how to find a useful
Definition of artificial general
intelligence
what we can learn from studying the
differences between humans and chimps
about intelligence in general
how we should go about predicting AI
progress and why Conor expects
artificial general intelligence faster
than most people this was a very fun
conversation for me and I hope you enjoy
it too here is Connor Leahy
Connor welcome to the podcast great to
have you on
thanks for having me been looking
forward to this a lot I've been going
through your stuff as I told you and
it's it's you have lots of interesting
things to to say
so what I want to start with is just
thinking about how we first of all
Define artificial general intelligence
and how we measure progress in AI so
what metrics should we use to measure
progress are we talking about economic
growth or perhaps benchmarks for certain
tasks tasks solving what's the most
useful metric here
so I think let's start by defining AGI
or like what I think useful definitive
API is the first thing of course is just
there is no Universal definition of API
it's ultimately kind of a marketing term
kind of like anyone calls it whatever
the [ __ ] they want you know we're
definitely not looking for the true
definition of a AGI yeah yeah of course
so just making that clear up front so
I'm not claiming like I have the one
true definition of intelligence or like
AGI or whatever I'm so I Define it more
out of use like okay what am I trying to
point at what is the property that is
interesting that I think that is like
diff qualitatively different from the
systems we might describe we have today
and so the pithiest answer I can give
for that is
uh AGI is AI that has the thing that
humans have that gyms don't
another way to point put this is an AGI
is not so uh I think it was a young the
Kun for example argued that ohagi is a
bad concept because you know no system
can do everything you know Alpha fall is
really good for the proteins HTTP might
be good like you know writing books or
whatever but you know you can't have a
system that does everything I think this
is actually a bit confused so for me AGI
is not a system that can do everything
Alpha fold can do and everything GPT can
do and everything Dolly can do it's a
system that wouldn't confront to with a
protein solving a folding problem
invents Alpha fold that's why I would
call AGI so would you say this is a
pretty high standard for AGI it's a
pretty high standard yeah I mean so I
sometimes as a meme use the weaker
definition which is
um just a system that can reasonably
learn any task at human or above human
level with you know reasonable amounts
of you know compute effort or whatever
this has the amusing memetic side effect
that I can get into great arguments to
people about that I think gpd3 already
fulfills this property
gbd3 can do most sequences sequence
tasks with you know a reasonable amount
of effort and if you can code most you
know human level you know office job
tasks into sequence to sequence
prediction tasks which is the case for
most of them
you know a large GPT model with enough
label training data you can learn those
for the most part not all of them just
many of them can't or like well I
wouldn't say can't that they currently
haven't or we currently haven't gotten
around to do but
so the reason I'm using the higher
standard is because people [ __ ] when I
use the lower standard one which is like
there's this the joke is always you know
when something is stops being AI the
moment it works and I think we've had
that that happen with gpt3 as well is
that if I describe what gpt3 could do to
the general like public or to like AI
researchers and I gave them totally
exactly what gpd3 can do and I asked is
this AGI they would I predict that most
people would have said yes
but now with hindsight bias like well no
it's not already really meant so
I'm using the higher standard for this
the purpose of this which is just if I
if it encounters a foot protein folding
problem does it invent Implement and use
Alpha fold and this is why it's
interesting to even discuss what's the
most useful definition of AGI because by
some definitions gpt3 is already there
by other definitions if you require
perhaps inventing new physics for for a
system to be to qualify as an AGI well
then there's a there's a large
differentiator between those two
extremes what about the the question oh
let's let's talk about the chimp
comparison actually so one question I
have for you is so what is it that
differentiates humans from chimps is it
our raw intelligence or could it perhaps
be our ability to cooperate or the fact
that we've gone through thousands of
years of social Evolution so is it are
humans primarily different from chimps
because we are more intelligent
so these things are not independent we
are most social because we're more
intelligent and we're more intelligent
because we are more social these things
are not independent variables so
at first glance if you look at a human
brain versus a chimp brain it's
basically the same thing you see like
all the same kind of structures same
kind of neurons kind of sure a bunch of
parameters are different you know see
some more spindle cells and then you
know the knot you see some more whatever
of course it's bigger you know human
brain is just significant but it just
has more parameters you know it's just
tpp3 versus gp4 you know small circle
big circle I don't know if you've seen
those means
um but it doesn't matter there's a bunch
of stupid people they're speculating
about how many parameters before we'll
have which has become a meme on a
Lutheran I know anyways so
humans are obviously extremely selected
for parameter count like that like
there's this
people want to believe that there's some
fundamental difference between humans
and chimps I don't think that's true I
think like actually you could probably
like purely like Genetically speaking we
should be considered a subspecies of
chimp like we shouldn't really be
considered like a whole different family
a whole different class we're more like
you know the third chimp you know
there's like the uh you know classic
chimp the bonobo and then like humans
like we should be right next to the
bonobo like we're actually super super
similar to chimps and here's a small
recommendation for any AI researchers
listening who want some interesting
reading I highly recommend reading at
least one book about chimps and their
politics it's a very enlightening
especially like France Duvall's books on
gyms because then there's a lot of
people I think have very wrong images of
like how this is a general thing I think
lots of people have wrong images about
how smart animals actually are because I
think lots of lots of studies in the
past about how smart animals were done
very poorly and like oh they have no
self concept whatsoever they don't
understand physics they don't understand
tasks or planning it's obviously wrong
like chimps obviously have theory of
mind like if you could you could observe
chimps reasoning not just about their
environment but about what other chims
know about the environment and then how
they should act according to that it's
like chimps obviously have theory of
mind I consider this totally
uncontroversial I know some philosopher
of mine will complain about this but I
don't care like chimps are always
intelligent they obviously have theory
of mind so you think chimps are more
intelligent than we a more sophisticated
cognitively sophisticated than we might
believe but what differentiates humans
is that humans have higher neuron count
is that it bigger brains that's the
that's the the main physiological
difference now there is of course
software differences so this is the
social aspect so chimps for example just
do not [ __ ] trust each other
so if two chimps from two different
bands meet each other it always ends in
violence or like you know
you know screaming or whatever right
like they cannot cooperate across bands
like gyms live in bands and within the
band they can't cooperate it's actually
quite impressive like so there's this
concept of the like chimp War bands so
like this is like a real thing so like
there have been chimpanzee Wars so like
I love when people are like oh you know
Humanity you know it's not the most
violent piece he's created it's more I'm
like man have you seen what chims do to
each other holy [ __ ] like it's awful
chimps are just the worst they're just
like the worst possible things
incredible like all the bad things about
humans like compress into one little
Goblin creature it's and we could think
about say if if humans lived in these
small tribes how much could how much
could we actually achieve could that be
the limiting factor to to what we we
achieve as a species how powerful we are
um as opposed to our raw intelligence so
it's a mixture of both for sure so
there's a few things that come into this
and uh starting spending so much time
with chimps but I actually think this is
really fascinating this is actually
useful for thinking about intelligence I
think when you're thinking about
intelligence is really valuable to
actually look at you know other
intelligences that are out there and
like try to understand them and like how
they work so I think not enough people
like pay attention to chimpanzees and
like monkeys and like how smart they
actually are and also other animals by
the way like crows are much smarter than
you think they are like they understand
like Newtonian physics it's actually
crazy
um
so
but there are limitations so like you
look at chimps right and they like they
don't really have language they have
like some like Proto language so they
have like Concepts and grunts they can
like change with each other they don't
really have like at least like grammar
or like you know like recursion and
stuff like that but they do have some
interesting properties so for example
chims are much better like absurdly
better at short-term memory than humans
like absurdly though like to a chimp we
look like like mentally handicapped when
it comes to short-term memory tasks like
if you flash like 10 numbers for a chimp
to memorize for just like one second
they'll instantly memorize it and they
can like repeat the exact sequence of
numbers and they do this like very
reliably now if you can get them to
operate which is another problem with
the intelligence tasks is that often
animals would just not want to play
along with what you're trying to do but
there are you know there's some funny
YouTube videos so you can see chimps you
know instantly memorizing you know like
10 digits and just like you know
instantly you know redoing them so the
human brain obviously is more optimized
is in other ways like we obviously gave
up short-term memory for something else
there's obviously a lot of weird
pressure evolutionary pressure when done
in humans so
the the main reason I say with humans I
think are extremely strongly selected
for large parameter counts for large
brains is
um I mean look at Birth in humans like
you know the size of the human skull is
so absurdly optimized to be as big as
possible without us dying during
childbirth and already childbirth for
humans is like
very abnormally dangerous for animals
like for most animal birth is not that
complicated it's like just kind of a
thing like the mother usually doesn't
die this is a complicated thing for
humans this is a very very complicated
thing and it's a and you know it's
really like the skull like even when
babies are born babies are born very
premature actually and their skulls are
so squishy it's like they're they're
their skulls have infused so they're
like literally squishy so they can still
fit so you can fit more brain and and
still have the child be born so if you
look at all that that's what it looks
like when evolution is optimizing really
hard myopically for one thing
so humans are obviously extremely
optimized they have as big of a brain as
we can fit we also have like some so if
there's like one adaption we have
compared to like chimps and like other
uh and like close animals it's that we
have like much more sophisticated brain
cooling like our like uh blood
circulatory system in the brain and our
cooling system is
unusually sophisticated and
so there's all these things that point
pretty strongly that humans were super
super hardly heavily selected for
intelligence but why we were selected
for intelligence exactly is a bit
controversial actually so there's this
very interesting
phenomena in the um
uh Paleolithic record where when when uh
anatomically modern humans emerged you
know they they came together to groups
they developed a what are called hand
axes which don't really look like axis
but they're like simple primitive stone
tools and then they did nothing
for like 70 000 years they just kind of
sat around and made hand axes they
didn't really expand that they expanded
but like you know they didn't really
they didn't develop art they didn't
really have like they didn't build
buildings they didn't have like you know
they didn't developing like more cop
didn't have Spears or bows as far as
we're aware of you know of course as is
always the case in archeology all of
this could be overturned by finding you
know one weird rock somewhere in Africa
so you know just for those that are
unaware about the epistemological status
of archeology it's a very Frost feel to
make predictions about but in the
current you know main telling of human
history there's this bizarre period that
I feel like not enough people talk about
where humans existed everywhere there
was lots of humans like these were
completely anatomically modern humans
and they did nothing they had like they
didn't develop technology they didn't
develop you know writing or symbology or
like anything they just kind of sat
around that's really really weird and
then very suddenly I think it was in
East Africa there suddenly was this
explosion of like art and like new new
terms of tools and you know all this
kind of stuff just kind of writ and like
and the way it radiated back over like
all the other tribes that already
existed outside of Africa and kind of
like overtook them with this like
revolution of like new cognitive
abilities
burial rituals and cave paintings and
the proto-religions all of these things
yeah yeah so so
of course is you know very fascinating
because like these are not anatomically
different like it's not like their heads
are suddenly twice as big or something
so these like you look at like like if
you look at Bones from like before or
after this period they look identical
you can't tell any difference at least
from bones but the behavioral
differences were massive and like the
cultural and like technological
differences were massive
sure looks like a foom doesn't it what
what's what is a foom corner so a foom
is a uh explosion intelligence where
suddenly a system that kind of has been
petering around for quite a long time
you know suddenly gets really powerful
really quickly
and so from the perspective of a human
uh this is still quite slow you know it
still takes like tens of thousands of
years and whatever but for the
perspective of evolution of like you
know some animals have existed you know
line you know exist for millions of
years or whatever suddenly we had this
you know you know pretty sophisticated
monkey you know it had like these like
rocks it's pretty cool you know for like
100 000 years and then suddenly within
like 10 000 years so again this is
before modern history this is still
prehistory this is still Stone Age this
is before we're talking about like you
know
you know modern culture this is like
before Babylon before or before all of
that
before all of that we still have this
some this small group so this may have
been literally one try we don't know
Mike's impossible to know it may have
literally been one tribe in East Africa
that suddenly developed technology that
suddenly developed art and just spread
from there so it's unclear whether they
spread genetically like whether this
tribe conquered the other tribe or
whether it's spread them medically
so I think the second is more
interesting I I again have this is all
wild speculation but come on this is a
podcast we're here to have fun so
I'm interested in the idea of it being
medic and so I think the main thing that
is different between chimps and humans
other than parameter counts which is
very important I think parameter count
gives you the hardware this is the first
step it's Hardware but really the
difference is is that humans
have means and I mean this in the you
know uh you know Richard docking sense
of like evolved
informational like you know programmatic
virtual Concepts that can be passed
around between groups if I had to pick
one Niche what is the niche that humans
are evolved for I think the niche we're
involved for is mimetic host
we are organisms that more than any
other organism on the planet is evolved
to share digital information or virtual
information or just information in
general this doesn't work in chimps
there's many reasons it doesn't work
chimps they have the memory capacity for
it but they don't have language they
don't really have also they're like
voice boxes are much less sophisticated
than humans it's unclear this is
actually a lot of neckline but like
actually another weird adaption that
like almost only humans have is there
control over our breath so most animals
can't hold their breath this is actually
an adaption that only some animals have
and humans have extremely good control
over their breath and this is actually
necessary for us to speak if you pay
attention to while you speak you'll
notice that you hold your breath for
like a microsecond like all the time and
if you try to breathe while you speak it
will come out like you know like
gibberish so yeah what what does all of
this imply for uh the difference between
humans and AI then is what we have to
imbue AIS with mimetic understanding for
them to progress what they have to be
AIS talking with each other in a social
way for them to become more intelligent
or is that extrapolating too far
so the interesting thing here is that
okay what does the memetic mean so
memetic is a new kind of evolution which
is different from a genetic Evolution
it's still similar in the sense that it
is still you know selection based right
there's some kind of selection mechanism
they're selecting some memes to be fit
and something well what is different
from genetic Evolution speed mimetics
are very fast you can try many memes
very quickly within one generation
without having to you know restart from
scratch I think that's the fundamental
um you know uh novelty is basically that
Humanity has that made us work is that
our we moved our evolutionary baggage
from our genes to our memes so the main
difference we mean like you know some
like my Paleolithic ancestor you know
other than me being you know frail and
weak compared to you know probably how
buff he was is mimetics like I just know
things I have Concepts in my mind I have
algorithms and like epistemology and
like you know culture in my mind that in
many scenarios will make me much much
more capable you know if you put him you
know next to me on like a you know
reasoning tasks or like you know
cultural tasks or you know writing or
whatever you know I would you know
obviously win those tasks every single
time
of course their brain will be
specialized for other tasks that would
be put back into the Paleolithic my
survival chances are probably not great
um but you will probably do fine
but it's interesting because the
different because it's genetic like I
could learn a lot of the things that the
probabilistic hunter knows you know you
know if I do enough you know weight
lifting and I you know have him teach me
how to hunt I could probably learn that
and vice versa if he was willing to you
know I could probably teach my
Paleolithic ancestors quite a lot about
mathematics and like how the world works
that's not how chimps work at all that
is not at all Hall tombs work and this
has been tried with chimps it has
actually been tried with chimps you
can't teach this you can't teach this
animals but you can teach humans so what
this means is that the interesting
unit of information moves from the
design of the body or the or the
implementation to the software it moves
to the training data it moves to the
algorithms
and so what this tells us about AI is
that AI is really
the obvious Next Step it's the it's only
memes
you know it's It's All Digital it's all
virtual it doesn't have a body it
doesn't need a body you know the closest
thing an AI has to a body is it's you
know it's like Network architecture
whatever but even that could just be
overwritten even that is just memes it's
just python files those are just memes
it's just information and AI can just
write itself a new body it can just
rewrite how its brain works those are
there's no reason to you know so you
know so humans are kind of this
intermediate step between like animals
and like you know whatever comes Beyond
you know Angels you know where like the
Intermediate state of like we have both
we're both animals and we have like
access to the memetic you know spiritual
realm whatever
but then the next step is pure software
and we have an enormous Corpus of data
produced by Humanity if say go back 500
years or so and that we can train these
AIS on so there is a we can we can very
easily import our memes so to speak into
the AI exactly and this I'm guessing
that this what this means is is that AI
can vary quickly catch up to where
humans are exactly and that's my
ultimate that's my ultimate prediction
is that you know I look at yeah it took
humans thousands of years you know
bickering in tribes to figure out you
know x y and z
uh I don't expect that to be a problem
for ai ai can operate much faster I also
think the to quickly get back to the
social aspect of this so you know
Humanity obviously social sociality and
like working in tribes and such was
incredibly important
for the development of intelligence for
multiple reasons like you know look up
the Machiavellian intelligence
hypothesis
um but
obviously a big part of this was is
externalized cognition so I think of
sociality to a large degree as another
hack to increase parameter account you
couldn't fit them inside one brain well
maybe we can like sort of jury rig
several brains to like work as one brain
and it like sort of works a little bit
so like you know humans in a group are
smarter wisdom with crowds you know
people with you know you know in a
society like a society is smarter than
any individual person this is like
obviously the case it doesn't have but
it doesn't have to be that way that's
not the case with chimps again if you
put more chimps into a pile it becomes
less smart because they start fighting
so this is not a inherent property of
groups this is a property that humans
have developed that you know took lots
of selection to get to this nice
property and I think again it's a it's a
hack for selecting for intelligence and
we wouldn't necessarily need this social
cooperation between AIS because we don't
have the limits that that humans have
AIS do not have to fit their their
brains through a birth canal we can
simply make the model as huge as as we
want to and therefore perhaps the social
cooperation aspect is no longer needed
what do you think that's true yep that's
exactly that's the second Point yeah
yeah I can just think talk to itself
it's much smarter why does it need other
people
Let's uh let's get back to the to the
question of benchmarks and and progress
so how do you think of of measuring
progress in Ai and specifically how do
you think of uh measuring whether we are
making progress in narrow AI versus uh
whether we're making progress in
generality
so this is an interesting question and
not just from a scientific perspective
but it's also interesting from a meta
perspective for info hazardous reasons
let's assume I had a one true way of
measuring whether a system is getting
closer to AGI or not I would consider
that to be very dangerous I would
consider the because it basically gives
you a blueprint or at least a direction
a North star of how to build more and
more powerful system so we're going to
talk about this more later I'm sure but
I consider the idea of building AGI to
be very fraught with risk I'm not I'm
not saying it's not something we should
do it's also something that you know as
obviously could be the best thing to
ever happen to humanity I'm just saying
we have to do it right and the way
things currently are looking with like
our you know you know levels of AI
safety and control I think you know
racing ahead to build AGI as fast as
possible without being able to control
or understand it's incredible danger so
if I had such a metric and you know I am
not saying I do or I don't I you know
um but if I did I probably shouldn't
tell you I probably shouldn't tell
people and if someone out there has a
true metric I don't think necessarily is
a good idea that to you know help people
Advance as quickly as possible I can
definitely say though that I don't know
of anyone that has a message that I
think is good I I don't know of any I
think all metrics are terrible I think
they're they're they all have various
problems my pet peeve worst one is like
GDP and economic growth that's obviously
the worst one like and why is that
GDP so I I recommend everyone who's
interested in this to you know pause
right now go on the Wikipedia and look
up how the GDP is actually calculated
it's not what you think it is so that
you you would think the GDP you know
measures like the value created or
whatever that is not the case so you
know Wikipedia for example which I
consider to be one of the crowny
achievements of mankind unironically I'm
not joking Wikipedia is like it's become
so normal to us but Wikipedia is an
anomaly there are most universes do not
get Wikipedia Wikipedia is so good it's
so good even so it has lots of flaws
sure whatever but it's so good and it's
free it's a miracle that something like
this exists like you know normal market
dynamics do not give you Wikipedia it's
like you know just like the pure
unadulterated idealistic autism of you
know thousands of you know dedicated
nerds working together and you know God
bless their souls
Wikipedia being free you know
contributes zero to GDP
there is no value whatsoever recorded
from it two societies one has Wikipedia
one doesn't no difference in GDP GDP
would measure for example the company is
working to implement the Linux operating
system but not the the Decades of work
uh creating the the Linux system yeah
and and so it doesn't capture all of uh
all of these contributions that are
extremely important to the world yeah so
basically GDP is kind of like perversely
instantiated to measure the things that
don't change
all the things that change and become
rapidly cheaper fall out of the GDP they
no longer contribute to the GDP so
so ironically the things that change the
least that become the more expensive you
know the whole bamos cost disease things
like you know as software goes cheaper
it contributes less to GDP than for
example you know like housing or steel
or construction whatever because that's
still slow and takes time and is
expensive and as people become richer
you know and you know software becomes
proliferate and everyone has software
but then you know Hardware you know and
like you know building and houses and
such becomes more expensive and they
contribute more to GDP so this is like
the most perverse like they so if we're
looking for a software-based thing that
we think will rapidly make massive
amounts of things cheaper GDP is like
designed to not measure that
yeah if the classic example here would
be something like a smartphone that
captures a radio and a GPS and a map and
so on and perhaps thereby decreased GDP
uh in some sense at least but so the
it's an interesting discussion whether
ahead whether uh finding a good
Benchmark for AI progress would actually
be hazardous it
I think you're on to something because
uh because
scientific progress often require often
requires having some North Star to
measure progress against and so we can't
really that's like
before there's some there's something to
measure progress against we we can't
have an established scientific field and
so establishing a a benchmark would
would perhaps help AI researchers make
progressing capability what do we do
then because we want to talk about the
rate of AI progress we want to talk
about what's called AI timelines and how
far along how close to ATI we are so how
would you have that conversation without
talking about benchmarks
there's multiple ways we can approach
this and multiple ways of like how blunt
I should be about it I mean the blonde
the most blunt thing is like
bro
that's it that's the answer like like
excuse me like please take take a look
outside of course that's not a very
scientific answer so let me let me turn
down snark a little bit and try to
engage with the question more directly
so
what is what are benchmarks actually
sorry to be pedantic but like what is
the purpose of a benchmark so many
people will say a benchmark is a
scientific tool that is something that
like you know helps you you know do
science or whatever I actually disagree
I don't think benchmarks are
fundamentally Versa they might also have
they might also be useful for that but I
do not think that's actually what
benchmarks are actually for benchmarks
are actually coordination Technologies
they're actually social Technologies
benchmarks what benchmarks are
fundamentally for is coordination
mechanisms the kind of mechanisms you
need to use when you're trying to
coordinate groups of people around
certain things and you want to you know
minimize cheating and freeloading Etc
a lot of Technology actually in a lot of
science once this is actually this is a
tangent but I think it's a very
interesting tangent that might be worth
talking about more maybe an hour later
is how much I think a lot of what modern
people are missing a lot of them are
science is missing is like the missing
science of coordination technology
there's like I I have like a small list
of like missing Sciences or like if we
were a better Society we would have
these as like established disciplines
another one is memetics which is like
sort of a science but not really
and
another one is like coordination
technology and like you know
coordination sciences and stuff which I
kind of exists but like not really and
it's super interesting but I think we
should talk about your predictions or
your way of thinking about prediction
predicting uh AGI before we we get into
coordination yeah so I actually think
these are very strongly interesting
because what is my goal of predicting
things so there's several things why I
want to mine want to predict things it
might change my behavior or I might want
to try to convince other people to
change their behavior those are two
different things that's actually
important to separate those one is
epistemological and the other is
coordination
so when you're trying to look at the
truth like is Agi come if that's the
question you're interested and that's an
epistemological question that's a
question of science this is a question
that might be solved with benchmarks but
there might be other methods that you
might use to solve this if it's like
science is not as clean as it's like
presented you know like oh you know your
false hypothesis or whatever that's not
how science actually works that's like
no one who actually does science
actually works that way
and the second one is coordination so
for coordination
benchmarks can be very useful and even
bad benchmarks can be useful for this so
if I'm interested in coordinating with
people it can be useful to like you know
say
um you know here's a bunch of tasks that
humans can solve and AI couldn't solve
but oh look now the AI can solve them
we've crossed the threshold for that
benchmarks are actually useful like I
actually think this is a useful
application of even very very poor
benchmarks if you're trying to
understand AI though ultimately you need
a causal model of intelligence like if
you don't have a model of how you think
intelligence works or how I think
Anthology emerges you can't build a
benchmark you can't make predictions you
need a causal model everything bottoms
up at some points that you have to make
predictions about intelligence so me
personally the reason I don't care
particularly much for most benchmarks is
that I expect intelligence to have you
know self-reinforcing memetic properties
so
I expect phase changes and the reason I
expect this is I look at chimps versus
Humans you know early humans versus
later humans you know modern humans
versus pre-modern Humans
Etc and you see these changes that are
memetic not implementation wise so we've
already seen some like
curious phenomena of this kind like
scaling laws and such so we have these
like scaling laws which I think a lot of
people misunderstand so scaling laws
give you these nice curves which show
like how the loss of performance
on the modeling smoothly decreases as
they get larger these are actually
terrible and these actually tell you
nothing about the model really they tell
you what one specific number
will do and this number doesn't mean
nothing there is some value in knowing
the loss but what we actually care about
is can this model do
you know various work can it do various
tasks can it reason about its
environment can it reason about is user
can I do whatever
and what we could see in many of these
papers is that there are phase changes
is that as these models get larger some
tasks are like unsolvable that they'll
have excellent like formal reasoning
tasks or like math task or whatever and
not like almost zero performance and
once the model hits a certain regime
they go through a certain amount of
training they reach a certain amount of
side suddenly they solve the problem and
like a very short amount of time what
this looks like to us is that we have a
model and it can't solve as a particular
task and without changing anything
fundamental about the model uh making it
bigger giving it more training data and
suddenly uh it develops what feels to us
like a qualitative to qualitatively new
capability suddenly it can it can
explain complex jokes or make make up
new jokes that that have never existed
before so
what I'm guessing your answer here is
that
because there are these phase changes
these these periods of quick progress in
AI this means that we if we look at a
smooth uh smooth rate of progress that's
not so interesting to see that the state
of the art improves uh every third
months or so because what we really
offer is what can the model do in an
absolute sense yes and we can get these
smooth curves but these smooth curves
are additions of
are sums of you know tens of thousands
or millions of s-curves and what those S
curves are where they you know where
they lie on this graph how to measure
those S curves now if we worry
sophisticated you know epistemologically
sensible scientific species we will be
studying that and we would have like
lots of like causal models of
intelligence and like how we expect
these to emerge and without predictive
theories So currently there are no
predictive Theories of Intelligence gain
or task there was no theory that says oh
once it reaches
74.3 billion parameters then it will
learn this task there's no such Theory
it's all empirical and we still don't
understand these things like at all I
think there's so another reason I'm kind
of against benchmarks and I'm kind of
like being a bit pedantic about this
question sorry about that is because I
think they're actively misleading
in the sense that people present them as
if they mean something but they just
truly truly don't a benchmark in a
vacuum means nothing and Benchmark plus
a theory means something there has to be
an underlying causal Theory and so what
usually happens is people present
benchmarks with no stated underlying
causal Theory so the assumptions are
just implicit and this is really bad
epistemology this is really bad science
if you don't have an underlying
predictive Theory then you your number
means nothing it has to have a context
there has to be a theoretical framework
in which this number means something and
a curious thing that we're seeing is is
that a lot of people don't even see this
as a problem you know like someone
presents a new Benchmark and they're
like you know this measures real
intelligence and um you know look all
the models can't solve my problem but if
they could they would be intelligent or
whatever or they don't even say that
it's just like implicit
that's really bad epistemology this is
really bad science the way it should be
done is like okay hey I have this causal
Theory this is how things intelligence
Works give if the theory is true it
predicts that in the future you know if
intel if we do this the intelligence
will do that here's a benchmark that
measures this now that's good science
like it might be wrong to be clear it
might be wrong like maybe the theory is
just wrong and like its predictions are
falsified but that's okay like you know
I mean it's not great but it's like you
know I would be like respectful of them
but I think currently there's a most of
our benchmarks are mostly marketing
coordination tools they're not of the
this is what I've consider a scientific
Benchmark this is something I would
consider to be a theory like an actual
science this is not the shape that like
any benchmarks that I'm aware of have do
we have any idea what such a causal
theory of intelligence might look like
I mean there are ideas but there's no
good ones like no one because
fundamentally we don't know how
intelligence works until you know people
sometimes then bring up like you know
icy and whatever and I think I see is
a very not relevant for reasons we can
get into if you're interested but what
you're referring to here is a is a
theoretically optimal or mathematically
optimal model of intelligence that
that's it's it cannot be implemented uh
in in actual Hardware yes yes you'd need
an infinitely large computer to run it
it's actually worse than that but let's
not get into too much into that so the
problem with intelligence is is that
intelligence is a her and remember I was
talking earlier about the missing
Sciences here's another missing science
embedded systems in in the sense of
computation so there there's some people
have been realizing this
um wolf Stephen Wolfram deserves credit
for being one of the first people to
kind of think about this that I was
personally aware of I'm sure he's not
the first one he's never the first one
even as we always claims he is uh I
actually like Wolfram even so he's a bit
you know strange sometimes
um
another one is the Miri so the machine
intelligence Resource Institute you know
back in like 2016 or something wrote
this post to an embedded agency which is
so to be sorry to quickly explain
Bennett agency is this idea of what are
the properties of an intelligence system
or Reasoner that is embedded within the
larger universe
basically all our previous like
mathematical theories about
intelligence such as you know Salam
enough induction or even just concept of
bayesianism does not work in the
embedded setting so there's like some
like really cutting edge weird work like
informationism from that tries to like
generalize these these theories to the
embedded space where you are trying to
reason about an environment that is
larger than yourself so you can't model
the whole environment also because
you're inside of it so you get into
these like you know infinite Loops the
model the environment well you're inside
the environment so you have to model
yourself but if you're modeling yourself
you have to model yourself modeling
yourself but you're modeling yourself
modeling yourself you have to model
yourself
Etc to get into these infinite loops and
you know very very uh you know good
alien very very lubian kind of like um
so you're thinking this is a this is a
limit to our current models of uh
current causal models of intelligence
that they can't do this
um self-reference yes and it's it's even
worse than that um it's even worse than
that it's um we don't have a widely
accepted tradition of thinking about
these kind of things so Wolfram calls is
like the fourth pillar or whatever which
is of course a very silly marketing term
but like whatever like he kind of you
know sees how the first type of science
was like informal you guys kind of like
made stuff up you kind of like maybe had
a little bit of logic like Aristotelian
logic but there wasn't really meant
mathematics the second phase of science
was kind of like equations you know this
is like mathematics you had like
formulas and you know derivatives and
like all these kind of things this was
like really pretty useful for building
models but then in the third phase was
yet computational models so you
generalized from equations to just like
arbitrary programs and now he calls the
fourth Paradigm multi-computation which
is the same as embedded agency
ultimately was the idea of both of
having non-deterministic programs and
also having observers that sample from
this non-deterministic program rather
than having a program that you run and
you get an output you have a
non-deterministic program which produces
you know some space some large num you
know space outputs and then you sample
from the space using some kind of
smaller program and this is what
intelligence actually is we are small
embedded programs running inside of this
large non-determinacy program we call
the universe and so this is the actual
like correct ontology for thinking about
intelligence and this is just not
something they're just widely like like
even like a ontological concept that
like exists in the head of many people
like I'm not saying no people like some
scientists do think about like you know
like um
distributed systems people think a lot
about this kind of stuff and like
various complexity Sciences think about
this kind of stuff I'm saying no one
thinks about this so that's not like a
widely accepted feel and at least to me
again this is just like all hot takes
you know podcasts speak and whatnot but
like
I think that like a good theory of
intelligence has to be formally to some
degree in this kind of some formalism
like this some kind of ontology like
this and it has and so and then it gets
even worse so the next worst problem is
is that intelligence obviously interact
with its environment so to have a good
causal model of intelligence you have to
have a good causal model of its of its
environment so like for example let's
say I have a system which is quite dumb
not very smart what happens to an
existing environment which includes a
computer which is super intelligent and
it's helping it well well now the system
obviously is going to be able to figure
out some like much more complicated
thing because it has like a teacher
right so if I want a predictive model of
how smart the system is going to be
after n steps or whatever I'm gonna have
to have a model of the teacher too
because otherwise you know I won't be
able so this is a really hard problem
and I I so you know I'll bring you all
back to you know step one
pretty intelligence is kind of a Fool's
errand it's like like we can make very
very weak predictions and because just
our theoretical understanding are like
models aren't pure ontologies of what
intelligence is but how it develops and
what that means are so primitive you
know okay maybe if you know we had two
you know 100 years more time to do
philosophical progress and statistical
you know Theory progress or whatever
yeah maybe that all right now
I kind of trust like
sensible gut feelings and like you know
empirics more than I do
any theory that I'm aware of or any
predictive theory that I'm aware of
maybe I'm there are some I'm not aware
of but and in in this context you mean
it got feelings in the sense of a person
that's been immersed in the research and
and are actually reading the papers and
so on of course uh in in as opposed to
uh you know someone taking a look at
look at this for the first time and
thinking you know oh where's this going
so you would you would oh no it's
complicated okay I mean the truth of the
matter is is that in my experience a lot
of people who know nothing about AI have
been better at predicting AI than people
who have been studying it very carefully
see that's interesting I mean I've been
I'm being smart I'm being snarky but
there is a
reoccurring phenomena especially in the
AI safety world where I'll be like I'll
talk to my mom and I'll be like so this
is AI stuff for intelligence like yeah
and like intelligence is super important
right it's like yeah yeah of course and
like you know because you saw all his
problems like you know versus chimps
like yeah yeah of course super important
yeah well you know you could probably
teach computers how to be smart right
like yeah it makes sense and then if we
teach these computers to be super super
smart they'll you know if you do all
these all these crazy things like yeah
it seems like yeah well we don't know
how to control themselves so maybe bad
things will happen if you're like yeah
of course obviously like of course why
I actually I had the same reaction when
I brought up AI safety to to my mom uh
she she's not at all that interested in
in artificial intelligence and so on but
she actually a
discovered in a sense uh the problem the
control problem or the alignment problem
herself from me just talking about
smarter than human artificial
intelligence so perhaps perhaps it's
more intuitive than than we were we uh
we normally think so this is so this is
the me being snarky part and where it's
absurdly obvious like AI safety is
treated at this like esoteric like weird
like you know like requires all these
like massive complex arguments to like
stand up and like I think I I feel like
I'm I'm the uh like I'm being I'm going
crazy like what do you mean this is like
such an obvious simple argument that
requires so few little ontological
baggage but once you talk to actually
smart people about this thing you know
people with high IQs let's say not
necessarily smart they'll say hi IQ
people who have you know made this their
identity to be scientists their AI
researchers they're pro-progress they're
Pro technology
a lot of them will be pretty damn
resistant to these arguments
and so this is a classic you know I hate
to call back to condom on but he was
right about this where he you know as
people get smarter that doesn't mean
they're more rational that doesn't mean
they're better at epistemology it often
means in fact that they're better at
treating themselves because they're so
smart that you know they can you know
come up with better rationalizations for
what they want to believe anyways this
also goes back to the Machiavellian
intelligence hypothesis that they like
you know mentioned earlier where one of
the theories about why humans were
selected so heavily so normally in
nature when Evolution selects for
something so heavily that like
everything else gets thrown out and you
know like you know you're like you know
even birth becomes difficult and it's
like a massive thing it's usually sexual
selection so that causes that so sexual
selection is when some arbitrary trait
becomes desirable to one or both the
Sexes so the other sex like optimizes
for that super there's like peacock
sales so like you know peacock tails are
ridiculous like if I was an alien and
you explained Evolution to me and I was
like okay show me some of these animals
he showed me a peacock I'd be like what
the [ __ ] like
what made why is this it's like it's
ridiculous so sexual selection is wild
and was one of the challenges to like
early darwinian Evolution actually or
like one of the things that Darwin got
right later on and a lot of people
didn't really believe it but like Darwin
did get right
um and so one of theories is that human
intelligence is actually a sexual trait
is that for some reason like for example
gossip or oratory or like storytelling
or whatever became a trait that was
selected for sexually and therefore
people optimize it super hard so like
one version is you know be like oh it's
about art you know we got the QT version
is humans reflected so hard to create
art and sing and dance and whatever the
more you know pragmatic idea is that is
Machiavellian is that we were selected
for doing politics Center for
backstabbing our Rivals for making
ourselves look good lying to people
misdeceiving manipulating you know stuff
like that seems pretty plausible to me
if I look at human you know General
behaviors
um
and but yeah I would love to hear your
take on simply
um how do you think about AI AGI
timelines what is what is yeah
right
um actual topic how do I think about
timeline it's a good question
and you know
the obvious truth is I of course don't
really know you know it's impossible
because I also don't have I think I have
a better folk theory of intelligence
than most people do but it's still a
folk Theory I'm not like under any
illusions that like
I actually understand intelligence I
actually know what's going on but I have
some folk theories which is why you hear
me talking about chimps and embedded
agency and stuff like these are things I
think a lot of people don't mention when
they talk about like I'm assuming you
taught one you expected me to talk about
like scaling laws and neural networks
and stuff but it's it's often often the
the things that come up
um spontaneously are the the things that
are most important and so this this is
great yeah and it's not just and it's
not just spontaneous obviously like my
models of intelligence are not solely
informed by neural networks my Theories
of Intelligence aren't formed by humans
and culture and chimps and you know and
also neural networks and computational
complexity and stuff like this like I
think all these things are important so
how do I think about an Amazon timelines
the truth is that I can't I can't give
you a full causal my full causal model
because my full causal Model includes
what I think AI is currently missing and
you know I might be totally wrong I
probably completely wrong you know like
everyone thinks they know how to build a
GI right and like I'm probably wrong
about what I think but on good info
Hazard practices I should tell you like
oh we have this many years because I
expect it's going to take two years to
figure that part out and three years to
do that one but my model is close to
that so like I look at
how I think human intelligence works I
look at like how I think it's different
from Chimp intelligence I look at
um you know
how the brain works what's going on
inside of it and so on and it's just
like it's complex sure but it's not that
complicated like you know it's like it's
not it's not like
non-understandable and like the more
progress you make the more simple it
seems to be
and
so I look at like okay what are like
fundamental limitations and it's very
hard for me to come up with like limits
that are so hard that I like can't have
any doubt in them and then I also look
at you know my own timelines in previous
timelines where like every time I'm like
well you know surely it will take this
long until this happens and then it
happens and I'm like well okay but I
can't do X but then they do X and then
I'm like so around 2019 or something I
was just like okay screw it I'm updating
all the way
and then I just
update you know as as the base you know
as the uh Bayesian um uh conservative
conservation of expected evidence goes I
was up I was surprised so many times by
how simple things were and how often how
simple things work and how fast I go
that I was just expecting to be
surprised which is non-rational if you
expect in the future you will see
evidence that will make you update in
One Direction just update in that
direction and so that's what I've done
so I know a very short timelines I I
think that if we don't see AGI very soon
it's going to be for contingent reasons
not for fundamental reasons I think we
have Hardware I think we have most of
the software we're about we're like two
to five insights away from like full
blown API like the strong version of AGI
now those two to five
things are not impossibly hard you know
I expect them to be you know as hard as
inventing Transformers which is not easy
you know but it's doable to think humans
can do so I think you can get all five
of these in one year if you're unlucky
you know I think like if you know people
search for the right direction worked on
the right things that the right
experiments were good at epistemology
and had good causal theories we could do
all of this in one year and then you
know that would be it
um but the market is very inefficient
um you know people are very inefficient
science is very inefficient
um so it could also take longer so the
joke timeline I usually give people is
like
30 percent in like the next four or five
years
um 50 by like 2030 or like 2035
something like that 99 by 2 100 if it's
not half by 21 Run 100 something truly
[ __ ] up has happened I mean we had
like a nuclear war or something and one
percent it's already happened but we
haven't noticed it it's in a lab
somewhere perhaps it's in a lap
somewhere and like people are like oh
you know it's oh look it gets cute but
like you know it's fine like
I mean as I said like I think it's not
impossible that like
if we had used gpt3 different or like if
you gave gpt3 to aliens who have like
good Theories of Intelligence they could
just like jury rig it into an AGI
because they like know how to do that
and they were just like missing like
they're like oh look you you did the
floorboard Max wrong and they just like
redo that and then it's you know Aji
like I'm like one percent or less that's
true but I can't dismiss it like it it
does not seem impossible to me
if you believe there's a say 25 uh
probability that we will get to AGI
within five years are you betting
against the market specifically are you
do you disagree with people who are
valuing stocks uh a certain way should
AI companies be the higher have higher
valuations and companies at risk of
disruption have lower valuations
yeah because the the market is is often
quite good at at pricing assets uh but
you just mentioned that the market is
inefficient so so
yeah tell me about this
the efficient market hypothesis and its
consequences have been a disaster for
Humanity that's all I can say it's
the
the idea that the market is efficient is
a very powerful and potent Meme and it
has a lot of value in this idea it but I
think people don't actually understand
what it means and get confused by it I
think even the people who invented it
didn't really understand it
um
I like like eliezer's like writings in
another critical equilibrium about like
free energy and such more but let me say
a few things about Vision market and
whatever
the efficiency of a market is a
contingent phenomenon it's an observer
dependent phenomena
so for you you know dear listener you
know who is you know sitting on their
couch and you know isn't a finance
person or whatever then yes from your
perspective the market will be efficient
for the most part the most part you
can't you know put 10 million dollars
into you know GameStop you know call
options or whatever and make a bunch of
money
yes but that is Observer dependent if
you the reader are actually you know the
smartest you know Jane Street Finn track
Trader in the entire world you may well
be able to put 10 million dollars into
the market and take 20 million out
that's a contingent phenomenon it's an
observer dependent phenomena and this is
also why for example if an alien from
outer space came with you know 3000
million IQ I expect they could extract
arbitrary amounts of money from the
market they could just money pump you
forever and there's just nothing you can
do about that so it's not just
intelligence based either so let's say
you're the assistant of you know a CEO
at some big company you get a phone call
and you say the CEO had a heart attack
he died
for you the market isn't so the
efficient market hypothesis says well
trading on this wouldn't help because
surely if this was problematic we'd have
already priced in of course that's silly
someone has to price it in you're that
person you can make a lot of money for
pricing this in of course it would not
be legal because of instant trading
whatever like assume it was the market
is now no longer efficient from your
perspective because you have information
that allows you to extract reliable
money from the market
by contributing that so of course once
you've traded on it then it no longer
then it becomes efficient again you're
trading with it makes it efficient
so
yes if I had you know
access to a large amount of money or
like I made a lot of people rational I
expect you know I've had my opinion then
yes the market would change the market
would become efficient and would trade
in regards to this obviously I think I
have I am like the you know the
assistant in this scenario is that like
you know I can see the CEO dead on the
floor and no one else has noticed it
That No One Believes or like very few
people
there is a more complex version of this
as well where as you said like you're
like okay should like AI companies be
valued whatever that's not obviously
true to me
um and the obvious reason is just a
control problem
like even if the if if I you know if the
market was like would price my opinions
even then I would be like hmm maybe we
should short all these companies because
they're gonna kill everybody so you know
it's not obvious how you would price
these kind of things markets are very
bad actually at pricing at least the way
we currently do markets there are ways
to fix these problems or like please
address them the way we currently do
mock Market they're actually very bad at
dealing with Black Swan scenarios like
low probability weird tail end high
impact errors a lot of you know the
classic like you know Nasim Talib kind
of critique of these markets and
whatever is that they trade volatility
like the trade around volatility where
it looks they look more stable and they
look like efficient in a short amount of
time and over long periods of time they
have blow up risks they trade for blow
up risks and I think basically I'm
saying this is the blacks one is this
like the way things are currently traded
is we're like it's a massive bubble is
that like obviously like assuming we
survived atriai
and that was like a thing I believe in
the market would survive that well then
yeah I could make it absolutely killing
from options right now like man I would
oh man I can make a trillion dollars you
know shorting and longing this like you
know putting up like the old super
leveraged option calls yeah obviously I
just don't think the markets can survive
that
is there a way to make the market work
for us if we want to have accurate
predictions here so the perhaps the best
option right now is prediction markets
but those aren't there there's not that
much money in it uh in those markets how
seriously do you take prediction markets
I I think prediction markets I me and
friends sometimes joke about how like
whenever we see a great a thing we
really like and it's not popular we
always joke it's anthropics is it like a
Satan Society you know would have
already developed AGI and already killed
itself so therefore
you know that's why our society is
insane that was obviously a joke don't
take that too seriously prediction
markets are one of those things it's
like of course prediction markets are a
good idea like you just look at them
once and are like duh like it's the fact
that the US Outlaws real money
prediction markets is the most Galaxy
brain hilarious thing like ever since
they also outlawed you know building
houses which is also just so
unimaginably Galaxy brains you know like
Silicon Valley biggest generator of
money ever okay let's outlaw people
living there we did it boys we've saved
the economy like unimaginable so I I
think prediction markets are simply so
there's problems with prediction markets
you know blah blah blah but like they're
so obviously a period to Improvement on
like everything they're trying to do is
that the fact we don't use them is a
just hilarious sign of civilizational
and inadequacy
do you think that prediction markets are
a bubble of people with short ATI
timelines because they look they look
pretty the people who are interested in
in uh say uh
metaculous for example like whether
that's a prediction Market or not we can
discuss but the people who are who are
interested in these prediction markets
are often also people who are into AI
safety and are interested in AGI and so
on do you think that's a bubble
I mean yeah it is true that if you have
inside information it's usually
suspiciously that people tend to have
similar opinions if you see the CEO dead
wow all the people who saw the CEO dead
have been shorting this company I think
it's a bubble
so yes it could be a bubble or they
could just have information so like you
know I've seen gpt4 right you know I've
you know I've seen what it can do and
stuff I know quite a lot about what it
can do compared to like current models
so like if such markets existed yeah I
could like make the money I'll make a
lot of money there because I know a lot
about it and
it's similar with like I think there's a
massive best price going on here
obviously it's like sure there is a
there's a correlation between people
going on these markets and being into
like short timelines and so on but the
question is is this that they just
happen to have this arbitrary preference
or is the actual causal model rational
people who investigate the evidence tend
to have short timelines because of this
I think it's the latter uh of course I
think that obviously so you might
dismiss this opinion but obviously I
think it's just if you actually take
these things seriously if you actually
look into what these things can actually
do if you don't just you know read the
latest Gary Marcus you know whatever
piece and but you actually like interact
with the technology if you think about
intelligence in a cause away you'll
notice there's massive mispricing going
on and it's just like massive
inefficiencies and these inefficiencies
are you know
like they're not random right like it
makes sense why these inefficiencies
exist and this is why real money
prediction markets are so important the
reason real money is so important for
prediction markets is because it
attracts the sociopaths and that's super
important you can't have a good Market
without the sociopaths you need them so
because the sociopaths will price
anything they don't give a [ __ ] you know
they're like you know because like if
you have markets that don't include
sociopaths you're going to get
you're always going to get missed
pricings based on emotions
and like Aesthetics you're always going
to get that you know people are gonna
you know find things because they think
it's good you know because it looks nice
or because it's like moral or like you
know socially acceptable whatever
sociopaths don't give a crap you know
and they'll just trade you into the
ground and that's what you want from an
accurate prediction market so you know a
lot of you know you know these
forecasting sites you know have people
who are super rational not and I call
them sociopaths but I'm saying that you
know they're they're you know nice and
efficient whatever but what you really
want what I want trading on my
prediction markets is you know there's
like some Cutthroat you know you know
Wall Street you know Jane Street you
know turbo you know you know math
sociopath like those are the people you
actually want making these calls and
they usually do it for money but you're
saying these uh options uh are these
yeah these options for betting aren't
available to you and so
is there a way to set up a bit uh
because you know this is saying that the
betting is a tax on BS and it might be
nice if there's someone someone
listening to this who thinks you're
totally wrong right what could they do
to earn money from you being wrong or uh
the other way around of course that's a
good question
um I'd be happy to make predictions
about for example what gpd4 can do I
mean for obvious reasons because I have
an incentive Advantage there
um but I would also be happy to make
predictions about the gpt5 or I'd be
like like Canada 2x with these certain
amounts of you know effort we can
actually formalize this in like bits of
curation
um if you want so we can make that
pretty precise the truth of the matter
is I don't actually care enough of
changing other people's mind to actually
make these bets but if someone offered
me like a prepaid pre-made like set of
bets I would probably accept it but
truth of the matter again better
coordination mechanisms remember we
talked before about how benchmarks
coordination bets are not actually I
they're in this case they're they can be
epistemological they can be valuable but
they're also ultimately coordination
mechanisms so like
if you present me with new information
that changes my mind or like if you
present me with a bet you know that's
like hey I know something that you don't
know and then I'm like and you tell me
that I just update I'll be like great
I'll just update I'm like not dogmatic
here right if you just show me hey we
did this experiment we have this causal
model of intelligence here's a causal
model here's why it doesn't it predicts
that you know
you know intelligence will increase this
quickly and it'll be like huh
okay and then update all the way because
that's what you do you know as the
saying goes when when I hear a new facts
I change my mind what do you do
fantastic all right let's uh let's end
it here and then um talk about AI safety
next